this tick tock came in of a grandmother
and let's see what she had to say
somebody get something here to eat i
won't
what's wrong with you you don't piss me
off taping me
[ __ ]
don't be talking ugly
you ought to not be telling people my
damn business i don't want to [ __ ] i can
[ __ ] you ain't nobody's business but
mine
amen to that amen that's five years ago
when five years ago you must be doing
that
why i'm too old no
so look right there you see uh
what's happening right here really and
this is unfortunate that this kind of
happens a lot of
older senior citizens are being used for
tick-tock clout
and you see that a lot man and right
here grandma got birded down about 10
years ago or something
five years ago she was working at a
panda express obviously
and uh i don't wanna [ __ ] i can [ __ ] it
ain't nobody's business but mine
somebody wanted to freaking warm up that
pink monkey you feel me
and um that's what happened and i hate
to say that it's pretty
you know i feel pretty dirty saying it
um but
you know we all know what sex is and how
it happens and that's insertion
so but uh
yeah people blasting out their
grandparents so they could get that
clout that tick-tock
faint they're doing the same thing with
mentals on there
you know you'll scroll through a tick
tock and the next thing you know you
logged onto a couple of minnows
and it's some guy over there eating out
of a dog bowl or something
are they putting you know they beating
them with it you know
you know pillows you know they'll get
two minnows out there and have them
pillow fight each other
you know before they get on a little bus
or whatever and it's just
that's what people are getting off on i
guess
and build building their clout with
and some of this who knows how it can go
how it could end you know that's what i
wonder how does it
what's the long term you know when i was
young they had a group that would come
to our town it was called
[ __ ] fist fights and it was this was a
group that came through louisiana it was
gay men would fist fight each other
i don't want to [ __ ] i can [ __ ] it ain't
nobody's business but mine
and this isn't my term for it this is
what they called it this was a different
time where people were
you know it wasn't about the wording it
was about who people are and what's
happening
and there was a lot of love and support
in the air and we'd go out and pay five
dollars to go over there to the bar
and uh and watch these fellas arm down
baby
i mean watch these boys just knuckle out
um and you know obviously one of my best
friends is one of the
strongest gay uh fighters in america
ever named
billy conforto
and he passed away man and i i gotta
reach out to chucky over there and we
gotta get a bench for him
over there in slidell and we'll see what
we can do so i'm going to do that this
week
but um
yeah so anyway that's what's going on
grandma's pissed man because she's
trying to get that wing that late wing
and you start to wonder as you get older
what's the last hurrah
when you're gonna get that last butt
that last bust you know that last suckle
when do you think it's too old when do
you think you'll shut it down that sex
you can hit the hotline for that as well
985-664-9503 when you're gonna shut down
that sex that booty magic
you know when you're gonna stop uh
doing that um that dirty david
copperfield you know paddle
you know i'm pulling that rabbit out of
your cooch gang baby damn
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one